a new group of Heroes some of whom we've
seen in action before are those who
haven't May pack a bigger Collective
punch than any team we've seen in the
MCU yet what makes them so formidable
mornings spoilers for Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 ahead the Guardians of the
Galaxy are gone long live the Guardians
of the Galaxy though everyone in the
team somehow makes it to the end of
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 alive
their mission is far from easy and
pretty much everyone ends the movie as a
changed person as a result the original
team effectively dispands and most of
them wander off to do their own things
however the Galaxy still needs this
protectors and does the freshly
appointed leader of what remains of the
Team Rocket assembles a new Squad that's
a healthy combination of old hands and
Fresh Faces along with him and groots
the new Guardians of the Galaxy are
craglin Cosmo the space dog Adam Warlock
Filer and possibly warlock's adopted pet
blurb it's a strong team when it comes
to Pure power Ruckus new Guardians of
the Galaxy blows the old lineup out of
the water with ease and could very well
stand among the very strongest MCU super
teams rocket is now playing the
Star-Lord role but he's obviously much
smarter and has access to fast Superior
gear he's finally dealt with his trauma
and emotional baggage and as he showed
in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 he's
also an astute tactical mind I want to
save quill so I can prove her better
than him Groot is still grooves but he's
grown into a super-sized form that's far
bigger and more powerful looking than
anything we've seen before craglin is
now in full command of yandu's Arrow
giving him his former Chief's power set
to go with his vastly greater
interpersonal skills Cosmo of course is
a massively powerful telekinetic and
very good dog the MCU versions
telepathic abilities remain largely
unexplored bursts of the space dog's
comic book Incarnation is anything to go
by she's no helpless pup then there are
the new recruits Adam Warlock entered
the Marvel Cinematic Universe by beating
multiple Guardians with ease the fact
that he's still basically a toddler
implies that his powers are still
developing when which seems likely
considering that the comics version of
warlock is a Thanos level Powerhouse
that my child
is the next step in our evolution
more powerful more beautiful as for
young filer the high evolutionary
rattles off a fairly impressive array of
her physical and mental powers during
her introduction and she seems to have
acquired some energy beam gadgets to go
with her innate power set if she's meant
to be the MCU version of philavel she
might turn out to be the most powerful
Guardian yet too after all her comics
Incarnation has operated as Captain
Marvel Quasar and a living embodiment of
death itself the combination of this new
team's powers and abilities is
impressive and individually there are no
slouches either it's probably no
coincidence that their introductory
scene features craglin arguably the
weakest member casually noting that he's
fully capable of taking care of the
approaching alien horde himself it's
clear that individual members of other
superhero teams would smoke individual
Guardians in a fight but as a team
they're a powerful highly Cooperative
units led by one of the greatest Minds
in the entire MCU as such as how to come
up with another Super Scene that could
touch them at the moment Cosmo alone
could float the original and just
helplessly above ground while the rest
of her team points and laughs the
eternals might seem to have a fighting
chance but honestly they barely managed
to guard planets while even the original
guardians of vanquished far bigger
threats than anything the eternals have
ever had to battle really only magical
characters like Dr Strange or wonder
maximoff might be able to score a
moderately easy win over these new
guardians but then that's an MCU wide
issue that affects just about every
non-magical character so are the new
Guardians overpowered thanks to the
team's historical pension for falling
apart due to interpersonal bickering and
the abundance of absurdly powerful
threats in the Galaxy probably not
they're almost certainly going to
feature in the future of the MCU in some
shape or form and with the whole
Multiverse becoming a bigger and more
dangerous place by the second the
Guardians of the Galaxy will probably
need every ounce of their strength going
forward
[Music]